the president first
but afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the final press conference of
the June European Council without
further ado I first invite the President
of the European Council tan and Swiss to
take the floor listen thank you okay Ben
good afternoon dear president during the
Rio summit we discussed the economic
situation if you be President Draghi
emphasized that the biggest risks to the
global economic outlook trade and
geopolitical tensions will take this
message to the g20 in Osaka we will try
to persuade our partners to cooperate
rather than threaten one another the
leaders discussed the further
strengthening of the economic and
monetary union we took note of the broad
agreement on euro area budgetary
instrument the European an inclusive
format will continue to work on this
instrument which will eventually be
integrated into the long-term EU budget
the leaders also expect work on the EFM
treaty to be finalized by the end of
2019 at the end of a meeting the eu-27
briefly came back to the issue of
dragazine we have agreed on the
following United approach of the eu-27
we look forward to working together with
the next UK prime minister we wants to
avoid disorderly brexit and establish a
future relationship that is as close as
possible with the UK we open for talks
when it comes to the decoration on the
future UK you license the position of
the United Kingdom were to evolve but
their withdrawal argument if not open
for renegotiation and we have been
informed on the state of play of
planning for a No Deal scenario last but
not least I'd like to thank president
johannes and his entire
team for an energetic and successful
presidency you managed to have 90 pieces
of legislation agreed in the last 100
days before the European elections
including on border protection reducing
co2 emissions and building a digital
Europe that is impressive you made good
progress on my first package and of
course you hosted last month
EU summit in beautiful CBO Europe day
that we will always remember multimers
Klaus Matsumoto Manya
thank you very much class thank you very
much Romania young cough the European
Commissioner yeah feeling dunk thank you
very much president I'd like to begin by
saying that the Commission is deeply
grateful for the work done by the
Romanian presidency this is the work of
the president the government and the
Romanian ambassador in permanent
representation in Brussels I'm very
impressed by what has been achieved this
is the first remain presence II ever I
have five or six behind me and yours
were as good as mine this is a
remarkable achievement for a first-ever
presidency I'm very impressed by the
cooperation we've had in French we
devoted most of our work today to
economic monetary union and its
deepening after a difficult start when I
began my term of office we
make progress and the fundamentals
improved compared with the starting
point at the beginning of outer office
and more and more Europeans I'm glad to
see have become reconciled to their
single currency today we approved the
decisions taken by the eager Finn
Council and the Euro group that the
recent sessions they took so I refer to
the budget instrument for convergence
and competitiveness
I refer also to the terms for the
revision of the treaty establishing the
European Stability Mechanism in this
connection we should not lose sight of
the fact that the ESM treaty should be
integrated into community law a lot
remains to be done in particular setting
up a European deposit insurance system
the Finnish presidency will be working
on that the issues concerning works it
was nothing new nothing new because we
repeat it unanimously that will be
nuria's negotiation after we've toured
with thank you and now president
johannes of the romanian presidency
thank you dear presidents this is a
pleasure for me to be here on behalf of
the romanian presidency of the Council
of the European Union together with
president whisk and president young car
yesterday and today we have discussed
many crucial issues regarding the future
of the European Union I will mention
some of them while also referring to the
work of the Romanian presidency of the
Council of the European Union in the
last six months and let me start for
with thanks for your appreciations
Donald and run Claude for us it is very
important as it was the first presidency
first the strategic agenda that we have
adopt it reflects entirely the 10
commitments we agreed upon at the CBO
summit the spirit of CBO as I call it
the key aim now is to remain united
determined and effective in our efforts
to implement this agenda and the chief
results for all Romania is strongly
committed in this respect I particularly
welcome that the main priorities and
lines of action identified in the
strategic agenda reflect our common
vision for the future of the Union this
is a clear sign of unity and cohesion
protecting our citizens freedoms and
values should be central in our future
common actions as we have seen an
increasing number of challenges that
emerge both within as well as beyond our
borders
recently the council formally adopted a
number of significant legislative asked
included under the Romanian presidency
in relation to the banking union the
improvement of labor and social rights
the deepening of the single market the
decarbonisation of transport and the
further enhancing of digital Europe this
is Europe at its best and I would like
to take this opportunity to thank all
Member States and the European
institutions for their support and for
their constructive approach that allowed
remain a presidency to conclude a
significant number of important
legislative initiatives second we have
discussed the future multi-annual
financial framework the European Council
last December asked the Romanian
presidency of the Council
to develop an orientation for the next
stage of the negotiations presidency has
worked intensively and I'm pleased that
his hard work and progress are
acknowledged in the conclusions of the
European Council third as regards the
discussion on the climate change I would
like to express my regret that at this
point a consensus for ensuring a
transition to climate neutral European
Union by 2050 was not reached I would
like to conclude by saying that I
welcome the fact that upon my requests
the leaders agreed to have reference to
the Republic of Moldova in the
conclusions in my opinion the agreement
of the leaders the strength and the
support for the Republic of Moldova by
concrete measures is very important
thank you thank you president I now open
the floor for questions I believe the
gentleman in the fifth row was the first
person with Politico a question for
president tusk following up on your
leadership discussions we saw a surgeon
turnout in the EU elections above 50%
for the first time in decades I wonder
if you could explain to those voters who
are excited to come to the polls this
closed-door process talking in a dinner
after midnight with the cellphone
signals jammed your own closest advisors
excluded or our conference room next
week in Osaka does this match what you
think voters are looking for or might
the transparency the policy of
transparency you adopted in brexit be
better served than having us guess who
you're talking about in these rooms
the the processes I think will pretty
transparent sometimes I feel that maybe
too transparent to be productive I'm
formerly I'm the organizer of this
process sometimes right what I feel is
that the public knows more about
possible candidates and a midden than me
it means that the transparencies on
every high standard and and level I will
I will consult the new constellation of
the European leaders with also was the
European Parliament I will start my
talks with for example with the
Parliament groups leaders already today
and I think this is the best method to
to have this parallel process among the
leaders in the council and at the same
time with with the European Parliament
and party leaders I am maybe it's your
feeling that I am too discreet but the
problems that I have nothing to add to
what I said yesterday and not because I
have some secrets here but I have
nothing new to to communicate today you
are right to say that last time it was
more transparent
it's in your in your case yes I was a
surprise you know for the public and it
means that every every process is a
little bit different than the others
thank you and we now turn into the first
row the gentleman in the middle media a
common question for all three presidents
what is the legacy and the footprint
that the Romanian presidency leaves
behind in a time when Europe transitions
itself from a political landscape to
another thank you you want me in English
or in Romanian okay thank you very much
well as I represent here the Romanian
presidency I think that you noticed the
ideas I present it in my exposing a
couple of minutes ago I don't know if it
is good to speak about a legacy you
cannot create the legacy in six months
that's an illusion but you can do a
decent work in six months and so let me
conclude in them in a way which probably
is bit unexpected for some few people
had high expectations when we started
our presidency most people expected us
to be well in between somewhere well
surprise
I took the load a CEO from Don Angelo
very serious and the fact that the
Romanian presidency concluded 90 plus
legislative files
you know how much have been concluded in
other presidency is an indication not
only of
the intensity and the quantity of the
work but also the quality because we
have partners negotiators and
institutions with high standards and so
our team the Romanian team managed
something unexpected and this is why I
said that the Romanian presidency was
surprising because because it performed
way better than expected so if we may
define this as a legacy that Romania is
actually way better than its image then
this is a good legacy I think that
everything is clear when it comes to
this excellent work and very effective
[Music]
way of working presented by the Romanian
presidency but for me it's also really
important my impression from CBO I I met
thousands of true European from the
streets in Sibiu I was really really
moved I visited also this Kirchen
amazing paintings collection in Sibiu
every in you know it was my feeling was
that we can we could touch the the
essence of Europe in Sibiu because of
because of this positive probiem
emotions because of culture because of
hospitality it's I think something
sometimes it's more important and then
our procedures and and legislation for
me and I it's not the slogan here I will
always remember this European days in
the Sibiu it was for me personally one
of the most impressive moment in my
political life I had in fact high
expectations
and I was not disappointed it was better
than I expected
although I had high expectations Thank
You Ann we now turn to our right Nicola
ways to be do stressed Petey I have a
question for all of you but particularly
for president tusk I'm rather surprised
I'm wondering whether yesterday or today
you had a chance to discuss the
situation in the Gulf from the United
States and Iran there's a chance there
might be a major armed conflict here and
I just can't understand how come
European leaders didn't have any
discussion of this so I'd like to know
whether whether you've discussed it if
you've discussed it what do you think
you're doing are the Europeans or so in
word turning that not concerned about
the situation in the world we address
today well I could put the same question
to the Brussels press they're looking
inwards too and they're not
concentrating on the major problems in
the world
mrs. mogherini the High Representative
and the foreign ministers have made it
quite clear through her what the
position is and that position has not
changed you know I think that sometimes
a better not to intervene the biggest
problems in our history was always
provoked by to active politics not not
too passive I think that of course we
follow the situation closely and and
very concerned about the developments in
the Gulf region but there was no
pragmatically no reason to to prepare
you know specific European statement on
on this I think it's our position here
is quite responsible
thank you and the last question goes to
the gentleman in the third row
Thank You Patti Smith Irish Times
specifically to miss mr. tusk
the the perception according to the
Irish Prime Minister of the mood of the
of leaders is that they are much less
tolerant than they were of the idea of
any extension of brexit beyond October
and do you have anything in the message
that you're sending to the British about
October and whether or not it's as
flexible as British candidates in the
British election election seemed to
suggest all the time frankly speaking we
have nothing new to add to our formal
position here and and nth opinion it's
and if you know we now we are waiting
for the new British prime minister and
we have to be very precise and also
patience it's waiting for for the
decisions of maybe new proposals but our
our position remains mmm if I if I
informed just five minutes ago which I
may be the the process of brags it will
be even more exciting than before
because of some personal decisions in in
London but it but nothing has changed
when it comes to our position thank you
very much this concludes the first
conference